- Why is your red meat video offline?
(upbeat music)
Victoria, thanks for asking.
A lot of people have been
speculating about this actually.
The reason I had to take the video down is
because there was some confusion
between the sponsor and myself
about what they were
comfortable with having
within the video as far as content goes.
And they wanted me to change something
once I posted the video.
Me being a person who stands
behind my medical ethics
and didn't want to change
my medical opinion,
we came to a mutual agreement
that we just take the video down.
What I want to say
about the red meat video
is that I still very much
stand behind everything I said.
You should dramatically reduce,
if not remove entirely processed meats,
and if you have them once in a while,
that's not a major risk
that you should be really worrying about.
Yes, overeating red meats
is not probably not ideal,
but eating them in moderation
alongside vegetables,
and especially preparing
them in the right way
like I said, marinating
them, not overcooking them
probably reduces a lot of these
negative effects we've seen
in some of the research.
And if you choose not to eat meat
because of ethical reasons,
more power to you, that's your decision.
But it doesn't mean
that you have to come at
and yell at other people
who don't necessarily
see eye to eye with you.
Whenever I make a video, sponsored or not,
I wanna give you my true, honest opinion.
I take that trust you
give me very seriously.
I will never tell you
what someone else wants me
to tell you, unless I stand behind it.
Now that being said, I will
work with all sorts of sponsors
as long as they are
letting me say my message
that I would say if the
video wasn't sponsored.
Stop just doing dumbbell curls.
You need to work out
the rest of your body.
Thanks.
Johnathon, I actually don't
do dumbbell curls at all.
I'm a firm believer in
doing compound lifts.
In reality, the way that
these guns come about.
I'm just kidding.
Pull-ups, weighted pull-ups, I do rows.
Those are the ways I
get my bicep workout in.
I don't think you necessarily need to do
nor is it tremendously
effective to isolate the bicep
and just do curls.
Krissy Pooh: I wanna know
if this is normal or not.
When I get sick my skin
gets painful to the touch.
Normal, the reason it's happening
is probably because you have a fever.
And when you have a fever, your
skin becomes hypersensitive,
so anything touching it
will feel like a weird, gross feeling.
And this probably evolved
as some sort of survival mechanism.
Totally normal, nothing to worry about,
as long as it's only
present while you're sick.
Lea Fa: What's your thought
on breast reduction?
I mean, it depends why you're
getting breast reduction.
I have a lot of patients
who have very large breasts,
and because of that they
develop serious back problems
'cause they're carrying so much weight.
Also, it can affect the
way that you see yourself
as a person, so it can hurt you mentally.
I agree that everyone is beautiful,
but I also think it's unfair to say
"Everyone should just be
totally happy with their bodies,
as is."
If someone has a bad scar
and they're feeling
self-conscious about it,
lying about it and just
saying that it's beautiful,
trying to convince them otherwise,
a little bit unfair
Some things make people
feel self conscious.
So it's about getting an honest
history, a true physical,
figuring out what the
risks and benefits are
of each procedure,
and making an individual
decision for yourself
with your doctor.
Rashiekah Love Toshinori Yagi:
Is it normal for your lower rib to pop?
No, I'm not even really sure
how your lower rib would pop.
The lower ribs are called false ribs
'cause they're actually not
attached to your sternum,
they're just sort of
floating in your backside.
Maybe they're rubbing against each other.
Maybe there is a tendon or ligament
that's getting caught there.
But if it's causing you discomfort,
please go see your doctor
because you really should
find out what that is.
I've noticed when I get extra tired,
I snore a lot and then I
wake up with a sore throat.
Should I see a doctor about sleep apnea?
Lindsay, you should
absolutely see your doctor
about sleep apnea,
because while sleep apnea
isn't an immediate threat,
it's one of these conditions
that causes chronic hazard to your health.
So you develop other medical problems
like high blood pressure,
chronic heart disease.
If you can control your
sleep apnea early on,
the less of these other
diseases and complications
you're gonna develop later.
My thing as a family doctor
is about preventing problems
before they become one.
And that's something you can totally do
if you truly have sleep apnea.
It sounds like you have sleep apnea,
especially if you're snoring to the point
of getting a sore throat.
Dana Habib: Hey Doc.
So I'm about to graduate from high school
and my dream is to work at
either the ED or be a paramedic,
but everyone is saying
that it's too traumatizing.
Is that true?
Ah, Dana, I don't want
anyone to dissuade you
from entering a particular
field you're passionate about
because in this life
passion is hard to find at times,
and especially in a field
that is incredibly rewarding
and a field that's incredibly
needed in our society,
I don't think you should
let anyone dissuade you.
What I think you should do
is you should go volunteer,
you should go on a ride-along if you can,
you should talk to folks who
actually work those jobs.
Once you expose yourself to the field,
you can have a better idea
if you truly love it or not.
It's very easy to fall in love
with the idea of something,
but once you actually start doing it,
you may not feel the same way.
So I always say, "Firsthand experience
trumps what anyone else is telling you."
So if you're passionate,
you wanna try it, go try it,
and then make your decision.
Hey Mike, can you get stretch marks
from losing weight too
fast? Love your channel.
Yeah, actually what can happen is
anytime you have a rapid change in weight,
you can get unusual marks on your skin.
I've had patients that
have had bariatric surgery,
lost a lot of weight,
not only do they get
stretch marks on their skin,
but they just have a lot of loose skin
and end up needing
plastic surgery afterwards
to get rid of that skin.
Now that being said,
you should still moisturize
your skin, that does help,
don't splurge on the
100, 200 dollar creams
that promise you removal of stretch marks.
Stretch marks, when you
grow rapidly in size
and then shrink,
actually come from a tearing
or scarring of the skin.
No cream is really gonna fix that.
Hurricane Devan: Hey Doctor Mike.
So I recently got braces on my teeth
and my mouth is really sore and tender.
Is there a way to help
me lower the pain quickly
so I can chew harder foods again?
I feel you.
You know why? Because
I've had braces twice.
First, when I was in high
school. I got a Invisalign.
And every two weeks, you had
to get a new plate put in
and it would shift your teeth
and it would be the most
painful, excruciating...
Once I got older, my teeth
shifted a little bit,
I had to get braces a second time,
and I had to get real braces,
like I had a metal mouth
while in medical school.
And it was a difficult moment
because I wanted to look my best,
but I also knew I was
investing in my future.
A simple trick that I used
that worked well for me is
there's some numbing agents
that work if you have like a
sore in your mouth. Those
can work well sometimes,
but in reality, the only solution is time.
And I know it's horrible
every time getting your braces tightened,
and it comes with a huge amount of pain.
So, first step, understand that this pain
is not a threat to you.
That alone can lower the
level of some of the pain.
But there are some numbing agents
that you can go and buy over
the counter in the pharmacy.
Obviously, talk to your dentist first,
but that could be a great way of treating
the first day of pain that you get
when you get your braces tightened.
Question: Tips for
someone with bad posture?
Tat, this is actually pretty
funny cause a lot of people
in my Curbside Consult video
and in my Resident Reaction
video, where I toured the set
with Manish Dayal, people
told me I had poor posture.
I sometimes have poor posture
when I'm interviewing people,
mostly because I'm 6'3" and
most people are not 6'3".
So I try to get on people's level
and that does hurt my posture somewhat.
But if you work with a physical therapist
and retrain your muscles,
you can actually improve your posture.
Is there any way to induce your period?
This is an interesting question, Jasmine.
I don't know how old you are
and I don't know if you've
ever had your period before.
I'll give you sort of the
medical background on this.
Primary Amenorrhea is someone, a girl,
who has never had her period.
Secondary Amenorrhea is a secondary cause,
meaning that you've
had your period before,
but now something is influencing your body
to not have a period.
So I'm not sure
what's causing you to
want to have your period.
Is it because you missed
it and you want it?
It's irregular and you
want to make it regular?
But this is a really good time for you
to go see your doctor,
have a conversation about
what it is you really want.
Because its really hard to
give you a simple answer,
when there's so many things
that could be going on.
Both from a health perspective,
but also in your mind,
why you wanna induce your period.
So to answer your question,
can you induce a period?
Technically, yes.
It depends for what purposes,
it depends on what stage of your life.
Go see your doctor, have a conversation,
and figure out what works best for you.
What do the other doctors at your work
think of your YouTube?
Christopher, we don't talk about it much.
The senior doctors that I've worked with
in the last five years, they
always ask what I'm up to.
They love hearing the
successes that I'm having
because they know how passionate I am
and how hard I work,
because I know you only
see what's happening
on YouTube or on social media,
but behind the scenes
it takes a lot of work
to make this happen.
Not only does it take a lot
of work to make this happen,
I never let my work in the hospital
or my patients suffer
because I'm busy here.
They're a priority, I love being a doctor,
and being one-on-one in
a room with a patient.
So I make sure all my work is done there,
prior to doing anything with social media.
So they respect me, they appreciate it,
they love that I'm
battling misinformation.
And hopefully, if this podcast
that we've talked about
in the past ever comes to fruition,
maybe I can get them to guest on the show.
Drop your questions and
comments down below.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)